y ahora que ya sabemos un poco sobre
configuraciones electrónicas
me gustaría que pensemos en los
electrones de valencia electrones de
valencia
son los electrones que se encuentran en
un átomo y que pueden reaccionar con
otros átomos para formar enlaces o
simplemente ser compartidos vamos a
verlo con más detalle usando las
estructuras de lewis los electrones de
valencia tienden a ser los electrones
con más alta energía
y los más alejados del núcleo
quizá estén pensando hoy pero los
electrones con más alta energía no
siempre son los más alejados o los más
alejados no tienen la energía más alta
bueno esto es verdad si hablamos del
bloque s que sería este bloque o también
si hablamos del bloque p que sería este
bloque pero no ocurre lo mismo para los
metales de transición así que no podemos
generalizar veamos algunos ejemplos
empecemos con el más simple de los
elementos el hidrógeno el hidrógeno
tiene un electrón y su configuración
electrónica es 1 s 1 y es un electrón de
valencia es el electrón que usará el
nitrógeno cuando reacción se lo pueden
quitar con lo que se convertiría en un
ión positivo
puedes simplemente compartirlo con otro
átomo que a su vez compartirá un
electrón con el hidrógeno y así el
hidrógeno puede fingir que tiene una
configuración como la del ello entonces
el hidrógeno tiene un electrón de
valencia y lo podemos dibujar como un
punto muy bien ahora qué ocurre con
otros elementos del grupo uno bueno
digamos que tenemos sodio cuál es la
configuración electrónica del sodio
bueno escribamos la versión abreviada
sabemos que inicia con la misma
configuración electrónica del neón cuya
configuración es 1 s 2 2s 226 eso es lo
que esto representa y para llegar al
sodio entonces tenemos todo esto
y luego 3 s 1 entonces cuántos
electrones de valencia tiene el sodio
bueno el electrón que se encuentra en
una capa electrónica que todavía no es
estable
es este electrón el electrón 3s 1 así
que el sodio también tiene un electrón
de valencia y este es el electrón que
puede perder o compartir para formar un
enlace ahora veamos otros ejemplos con
más electrones de valencia que el
hidrógeno o el sodio lo más importante
aquí es entender que todos los elementos
que se encuentran en el grupo 1 tienen
un electrón de valencia que podrán
perder para formar unión o que podrán
usar para formar un enlace
ahora pensemos en el yo
el helio es un elemento muy interesante
porque a diferencia de los otros gases
nobles que tienen 8 electrones de
valencia el helio solo tiene 2
electrones de valencia y como en la
primera capa sólo necesitamos 2
electrones para que sea estable es por
eso que el helio se encuentra en este
grupo
entonces el helio tiene 12 electrones de
valencia y su configuración electrónica
es 1 s 2 se encuentra en este grupo
porque es muy estable e inerte como los
gases nobles y tal vez estén pensando si
tiene 12 electrones de valencia quizá
debería estar en el grupo 2 porque todos
los elementos del grupo 2 tienen 2
electrones de valencia verdad bueno eso
tiene sentido podríamos poner al él
en el grupo 2 porque tiene 2 electrones
de valencia vamos a ponerlo ahí ahí está
ahora veamos uno de los elementos más
interesantes de la tabla periódica que
forma parte importante en la base de la
vida como la conocemos los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y tomando en cuenta lo
que acabamos de ver traten de averiguar
cuántos electrones de valencia tiene el
carbono y cómo sería su estructura de
louis bueno la configuración electrónica
del carbono empieza con la misma que
tiene el helio
elio más 2 s 22 s 2 y dos p2
p 2 entonces cuántos electrones tiene el
carbono en su última capa y que todavía
no está completa bueno tiene estos 4 2
más 2 y podemos dibujarlos como 1234
electrones de valencia pero esto porque
es importante bueno ahora que podemos
ver los electrones de valencia del
carbono y también podemos ver la
estructura de louis del hidrógeno
podemos predecir qué tipo de moléculas
se pueden formar entre el carbono y el
hidrógeno por ejemplo al carbono le
gusta fingir que tiene más electrones
para sentirse más estable como el neón
un gas noble y al hidrógeno le gusta
sentir que al menos tiene 2 electrones
en su capa
para sentirse más estable como el helio
entonces si este es el átomo de carbono
y agregamos átomos de hidrógeno a su
alrededor los dibujar es de otro color
podemos imaginar que el carbono comparte
sus 4 electrones de valencia con 4
hidrógenos diferentes y a cambio cada
uno de esos hidrógenos comparten un
electrón así el carbono puede fingir que
tiene 8 electrones de valencia y cada
hidrógeno puede fingir que tiene 12
electrones de valencia así es como
podemos predecir que esta molécula se
puede formar y si piensan que debe
existir alguna molécula como esta en la
naturaleza y que sea estable están en lo
correcto
es una molécula de metano y la hemos
dibujado usando la estructura de louis
aunque no se acostumbra a escribirlo así
cada uno de estos pares de electrones se
representa como un enlace covalente este
es un enlace covalente este par es un
enlace covalente y este par es un enlace
covalente entonces cada uno de estos
enlaces representados electrones así el
carbono puede fingir que tiene 2 468
electrones y cada hidrógeno puede fingir
que tiene 2 electrones y que es más
estable entonces cualquier elemento que
se encuentre en el grupo del carbono
tendrá 4 electrones de valencia por
ejemplo en el caso del estaño el estaño
pero tiene 50 electrones pero solo los
electrones de valencia son los que van a
reaccionar y son 1 2 3 4 electrones en
la última capa electrónica 1 2 3 4 y
quizá puede reaccionar como el carbono o
como el silicio incluso muchas personas
creen que puede existir vida en otros
planetas pero que no está basada en el
carbono sino más bien en silicio porque
el silicio puede formar estructuras muy
parecidas a las que forma el carbono
veamos lo que ocurre con los metales de
transición es decir con los elementos
del bloque t y del bloque efe como ya
sabemos cuando nos encontramos en el
cuarto período digamos que queremos
conocer la configuración electrónica del
hierro para la configuración electrónica
del hierro podemos empezar con la
configuración del argón y luego tenemos
cuatro s 2 4 s 2 y después pasamos al
bloque b en donde no llenamos el psuv
orbital 4 sino más bien el psuv orbital
3d así que tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
es de 6 y aquí es en donde se vuelve más
complicado cuáles son los electrones con
más alta energía son estos electrones de
y cuáles son los más alejados son los
electrones que se encuentran en la
cuarta sub capa los cuatro ese 2 es por
eso que la reactividad del hierro al
menos basándonos en esta configuración
es un poco difícil de predecir
se sabe que el hierro puede perder un
electrón dos electrones
o tres electrones así que puede existir
una combinación de electrones de más
alta energía con electrones más alejados
del núcleo y es difícil de predecir
algunos libros dicen que todos los
metales de transición tienen 12
electrones de valencia porque tienen la
configuración 4 s 2 pero
en realidad eso no ocurre con todos
porque existen casos especiales como el
cobre y cromo que sólo tienen la
configuración 4 s 1 y después empiezan a
llenar el orbital 3 de dependiendo de
las circunstancias aunque algunas veces
ocurre diferente pero incluso para otros
elementos de transición como el hierro
no es el caso estos dos no son los
únicos electrones que pueden reaccionar
porque algunos electrones de que son los
electrones de más alta energía pueden
involucrarse en alguna reacción y pueden
ser tomados o formar un enlace